He is the most bankable star in Hollywood and action hero with a massive ripped
physique who has impeccable comedic timing and a never ending supply of charm is
also one of the greatest wrestling superstars to ever emerge from the stables of
the wwe and the only third generation wrestling star in history.
The story of Dwayne Johnson,
the rock is a tale of dedication,
gris and old fashioned hard work.
In this week's biographics,
we chart the rise and the rise of 2016,
the sexiest man alive.
Dwayne Johnson,
Wayne Douglas Johnson was born on May,
the second 19,
72 in Haywood county,
California.
His mother after was Samoan origin while his father wade was a black Nova
Scotian Wade's ends living as a professional wrestler under the name of Rocky
Johnson.
To further entrenched the wrestling gene in his blood.
Dwayne's maternal grandfather also had been a professional wrestler,
promoted as high chief Peter Maivia.
He was the first simone wrestler to break into the big time.
A generation later rocky became the first black champions who conquered the
state wrestling scene.
Rocky hustled as a wrestler taking on bouts web ever.
He could in order to support his family,
times were tough with the family moving from state to state in order to keep
pace with the wrestling venues.
In fact,
during Dwayne's formative years,
the family of three lived in 38 of the 50 states as they became entrenched in
the gypsy wrestling lifestyle.
The only time Dwayne got to see his dad was when he went on the road with him.
He cherished these times and quickly fell in love with everything to do with
professional wrestling.
His Dad taught him some basic moves,
including the sleeper hold when he was 11.
Dwayne was playing wrestling one school,
lunchtime.
When you put the,
uh,
hold on a classmate,
the kids immediately parsed out.
Unfortunately,
rocky had him showing his son how to bring someone out of the sleeper hold.
The ambulance and the police were called and rocky has to come down to revive
the students.
The Johnson House became a hangouts for Dwayne.
Schoolmates knew that they were going to have to do several rounds with their
host.
Dwayne would turn these events into mock TV shows where he would pretend to
interview the restless.
He would even interview himself as he portrayed the bad guy.
His chairmanship was immediately evidence as he came out with all sorts of
outrageous pronouncements against his intended victims do.
I excelled in a number of sports physically.
He was miles ahead of his classmates.
He had his first weight workouts when he was 13.
He had been tagging along with his down to the gym since he was five years old,
as he sounds quietly on a bench and watched proudly as rocky pounded out pset
after pset with Gargantuan weights.
Dwayne breathed in the gym atmosphere and marveled at the sight of huge men
doing seemingly impossible things with massive loads of iron.
While other deans took their kids to the playgrounds at rocky,
took Dwayne to most of the hardcore gyms in the country.
It was here that the future superstar learns that there was no replacement for
pure gut wrenching hard work.
At the age of age,
rocky allowed Dwayne to participate in sports.
He tried baseball,
soccer,
martial arts,
and gymnastics.
What he really longed to do is lift weights,
but it'd have to wait a few more years to get into that.
Finally,
on his 13th birthday,
his dad took him to a local gym for his first ever weights workouts and obvious
place to start was the bench press,
which had studied for years as his dad's.
Now this Preston,
massive amounts of steel from their chest.
Rocky had his son start with an unloaded bb.
He pumped out 10 reps with no problem,
so rocky added a 20 lbs plates to eat.
Jens.
This time dwayne pushed out eight easy wraps,
impressed,
rocky,
asked his son if he wanted to try the 45 pounders.
Dwayne nodded his head,
his dad stood behind him and lifted the bar off the supports,
and Dwayne got buried under the 135 pound weight.
He felt embarrassed and ashamed as if he had let his dad down.
That feeling fueled and intense desire to get better at the bench press.
And within a few years he would be benching 400 pounds between the ages of 14
and 15.
Dwayne excelled in the gym.
By the time you entered high school,
he had grown it to a towering six foot three inches and tip the scale at 225
pounds is imposing physicality,
gave him a great deal of self confidence,
which sometimes bordering on arrogance,
but his unstable home life that of his father constantly traveling,
left him directionless when he wasn't pounding the weights.
As a result of this,
he started to get into trouble.
It came to a head when he was 15 and he got arrested for check fraud.
His parents had to come and collect them from the police station when he looked
at his mother and father and he realized that despite living from paycheck to
paycheck,
he was the biggest source of stress in their lives.
In that moment,
he vowed that he would never cause problem for his parents again.
Although that was the last time that Dwayne got arrested.
It wasn't the last time he caused worry for rocky and data and facts of that
very next day at school.
He goes into a fight and it's knocks the other kid out.
It sounds in a two week suspension.
Upon returning to school,
he decided that the students bathrooms was not good enough for him and so we
decided to use the teachers.
One when asked to leave,
he was rude to the teacher and trying to intimidate him with his physical
presence.
That Nice Dwayne felt pangs of guilt at the way he had treated the teacher,
so the next day he marched into the deepest class and holding out his hand,
said that he wanted to apologize for the way he had acted.
The day before the teacher stared at Dwayne's hand for a moment and then grabs
this and told Wayne that he appreciated the apology then still holding the boy's
hand and he said,
I want you to play football for me.
Football proof to be a positive outlet for Dwayne's frustrations and
aggressions.
Providing him with a renewed sense of focus under the eye of coach Judy Swick.
He steadily improved both as students and as an athlete,
but at the time he was a high school senior.
He was ranked as one of the top 10 defensive tackles in the country and it was
offered a scholarship to the University of Miami.
The number one college team in the United States that Miami Dwayne's combination
of size,
strength,
and athleticism coupled with his strong work ethic,
makes him a standout from the very beginning.
Practice was going great and he was primed to be the only freshman on the
varsity team,
but then tragedy struck on the last day of practice with pads.
He crushed the grounds with his full weight on his shoulder.
It was dislocated and the number of ligaments were torn that night.
He had reconstructive surgery and was told that it need a year to recover.
He was not able to play before the season had even begun.
Dwayne,
he fell into a deep depression and not even bothering to go to class.
Then without even attempting and eve as midterms.
He hopped on a flight and returned home,
which at that time was in Tampa,
Florida.
After a couple of weeks,
he got a call from Miami's head coach,
Dennis Erickson.
He told Duane that he wants to be back at school in two days because he wants
you to talk to him when they mess up.
Erickson was furious with Johnson.
He told him that he had embarrassed himself and the team Erickson had trusted
him with a position of responsibility and leadership and he had completely let
him down.
Ericsson then placed Dwayne onto academic probation.
He was to attend every class,
every practice,
and every game simply sitting on the sideline.
However,
to get it into daily practice,
he had to get the signatures of every one of his professors attesting that he
had been to class that day.
If he didn't,
he would lose his scholarship.
Dwayne dug deep and did what had to be done.
He eventually became academic captain in his junior year and was preseason all
American.
He graduated from Miami University in Nineteen Ninety five with a bachelor of
general studies and criminology and physiology.
It was at the University of Miami that Dwayne first met Danny Garcia,
his future wife.
They were married in 1997 and divorced 10 years later.
After a years injury recovery,
Dwayne wasn't quite as fast or mobile as he was on the football field.
He was taken from the team and replaced by Warren Sapp after graduation from
Miami.
Dwayne,
when to Calgary.
Canada is a practice squad player for the stampeders.
Things were tough am in Canada.
You had hardly any money and very few prospects,
but things got worse when he was cut from the stampede.
A squad after just two months
arriving back at his parents' tiny apartments in Tampa,
Dwayne was now at rock bottom.
It his football career,
whereas effectively over at do,
you needed to look in another direction.
He thought deeply and realized that his life and his passion had always been
professional wrestling.
If he never turned his hand to it,
he would ever be unfulfilled and if he was going to step into that wells,
well now is the time.
His mother runs.
Girlfriends encouraged him to go for it,
but Dwayne's dad had major reservations.
Rocky knew firsthand just how tough the life of wrestler was and he wanted more
for his son,
but he vowed to stands behind his son.
So long as he put in 110 percent effort into becoming successful.
Rocky now became Dwayne's fulltime wrestling coach.
From the start though,
he talks him much more than simple wrestling moves.
He taught him how to be a showman.
After a few months of intensive work,
rocky felt his son was ready to take the next step.
He goes in touch with a former wrestler named Pat Patterson,
who was now a talent agents.
Patterson came to check out what's Dwayne looks like in the ring,
impressed.
He arranged for a signing with the wwe.
Dwayne was put into the minor leagues and it was given the name rocky Maivia in
homage to both his father and his grandfather.
He started wrestling and smaller arenas for $20 a pop,
but it didn't take long before he got his break.
The 1996 wwe survivor series was televised live on tv from Madison Square Garden
and to the new kids on the block was rocky Maivia.
He made an immediate impression establishing himself as a rising wwe star by
becoming the last man standing.
Rocky took on a charismatic in your face persona,
which proved to be too loud and too arrogant for many diehard wwe fans.
His character was rejected for being too tacky and fans came to see rocky Maivia
as an extremely unlikable character.
When he wrestled,
the stadium would be listed with signs,
reading rocky socks and a die rocky die,
but his perseverance and the constant refining of his character.
Eventually one of the fans over fans getting to appreciate the much of rocky's
narcissism,
was tongue in cheek,
much in the mold of Muhammad Ali,
and they began to enjoy his over the top sense of humor when he shortened his
name to with the rock.
Fans embraced this,
and within a year he had transformed the wrestler.
Everyone loves to hate to the People's champ
from 1997 and 1998.
So the rock had ongoing battles with stone cold Steve Austin,
triple h and mankind's throughout 1999,
the wwe championship belts pause between the Rock and mankind several times
during a series of epic encounters.
Then towards the end of 99,
the two team dumped it,
become the rock and socket connection and went on to win the tag team
championship three times the Rock and mankind also performed comedy skits on wwe
live telecasts.
One of them was a take of this is your life in which mankind interviewed people
from the rocks past the segment drew in eight point four Nielsen Rating,
one of the highest ever for a wwe segments in 2011.
Though the Rock was suspended indefinitely.
During the airing of raw is war.
He used the suspension as an opportunity to move into the action and Rena still,
he would return again and again to the wrestling ring in 2011.
He was the host of Wrestlemania.
He spent a large part of the promo buildup,
insulting and taunting John Cena,
who he had already been calling out on social media.
A few develops between the two,
which continued for another two years.
When he finally stepped away from the wrestling ring.
In 2016,
the rocket established himself as one of the great pro wrestlers of all time.
Hulk Hogan himself dominating wwe figure refer to him as the biggest superstar
in the business of sentiments,
which was echoed by John [inaudible].
One of his many catchphrases.
Lay the smack down,
inspired the title of televisions.
Second longest running series smack down the rock is also entrenched himself in
the wwe record books.
He was the first wrestler to win the WWF wwe championship seven times and it's
intercontinental championship reign of 265 days is the longest in the modern
era.
Dwayne's huge popularity as a wwe character allows him to crossover into
mainstream media.
His first acting job was in the 1999 episode of that seventies show in which he
played his own father in 2010 period and star Trek Voyager isn't alien.
Wrestler,
his first movie appearance was a small role in 2000 and one's the mummy returns.
The movie was a smash hit leading to a reprisal of this role.
This time as the lead in the movie,
the Scorpion King Johnson was paid five point $5,000,000 in that role,
ending in a spot in the Guinness Book of Records as the highest paid actor in a
debut disliked it actually being his second movie.
This movie established Johnson as a bonafide star with his comedy credentials,
clearly established through his wrestling career,
his next film,
the action comedy,
that rundown was the natural next step.
This was followed with a remake movie walking tool.
This role cemented Johnson's position as the ultimate hard as nails action hero
with a heart of gold over the next few years.
Dwayne skip between comedies and action movies with such films as be cool doom
to theory of film,
which was originally written for one of the rocks heroes,
Arnold Schwartzenegger,
and the fast and the furious.
His debut in the foster and the furious came in the fifth movie after fans
demanded to see a showdown between Johnson and vin diesel.
The movie was the most successful in the entire franchise,
making more than $86,000,000 on its opening weekends.
This remains to this day,
the biggest opening for any Johnson Movie Dwayne has interspersed his movie
roles with the parents,
is on a number of TV shows.
Many of them aimed at a pre teen audience,
hip heads and episodes of Corey in the house and the wizards of waverly place.
And was the host of the nickelodeon kids' choice awards in 2009 that yet he also
appeared several times on Saturday night live where he introduced his rock
obamacare character that morphing of President Obama with the incredible hulk.
By the end of the two thousands,
Johnson had developed a reputation as a bankable star who could not only carry a
new movie,
but also had a proven record of being able to revive franchises that were
getting tired.
He became known as very busy accent with at least a couple of new movies coming
out each year in 2013 Johnson start in a couple of true life based movies,
painting Dane and said PA states.
He also announced that year that he was to executive produce star in an HBO TV
series set in the world of professional football,
gold bullets.
And December of 2013 Forbes magazine named Johnson as the highest paid actor of
the year with earnings of one point $3,000,000,000 bullis which debuted on Hbo
in June of 2015,
proved to be a huge success.
Johnson,
he plays Spencer strathmore,
red retired NFL player who goes onto a career as a financial planner for current
NFL players,
received props for his charm and depth as of 2018.
The show is in its fourth season in 2014.
Johnson played the tangible character in okay case for this role.
He steps off.
He's already grueling workouts and nutrition protocol in order to get as
impressively muscular as possible.
It followed this up with a huge disaster hits San Andreas before switching back
to comedy with Central Intelligence Alongside Kevin Hart,
2016,
so Johnson teaming up with Zac Efron for a feature movie version of the classic
beach and Dave's Stevie series Baywatch.
The two hockey actors created the loss of prerelease buzz with that epic beach
workouts in which Johnson would present with gut busting physical challenges.
The movie however,
was a box office disappointments.
Johnson finished out 2016 by learning that he had been voted people magazine's
sexiest man alive.
The next big project was a remake of the Robin Williams classic Jumanji Johnson,
along with Costars,
Jack Black and Kevin Hart's.
Brought a new updated angle to the story that resonated with fans,
the movie it has so far brought in $829 million dollars on a $90,000,000 budget
throughout his life.
Dwayne has had one constant that kept him grounded and which he credits as the
basis of everything that he's achieved and that's the gym from those earliest
days when he would sit and watch his father dominated the weights.
In the 19 seventies,
the sights,
smells,
and sounds of working ask became an integral part of his being.
Dwayne's workout intensity and dedication.
I've been an inspiration to millions.
He hits the gym at 4:00 AM every morning,
training for up to two hours with heavy basic compounds,
moves in,
dispersed with cardio to keep his body fat percentage into the single digits.
He is also a favorite in the bodybuilding community.
Appearing as a guest host at the 2016 Mr Olympia competition since 2014.
Dwayne has been living in southwest ranches in Florida is fast child.
Simone was born in 2001 while he was still married to her mother,
Danny.
In 2015,
his second daughter,
jasmine was born to his girlfriend of nine years,
Lauren Hashi and Dwayne Johnson has arisen from humble beginnings to establish
himself as the most bankable movie star of the 21st century.
In the process,
he is brought back to your mainstream entertainment,
the sort of Alpha male persona that has been so absent for so long.
He has become the people's champion once again,
so I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every so hit that subscribe button
below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday.
Won't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
suffering the archive over there on the race and as always,
thank you for watching.
Okay.